mr trump can we get your reaction to the
raid
he wasn't at his home in florida and
made no comment leaving trump towers in
new york
but the former president issued a
statement claiming mar-a-lago his home
at palm beach was in his words under
siege being raided and occupied by a
large number of fbi agents and that
they'd even broken into a safe
the secret service there to provide
protection confirmed it had facilitated
the execution of a search warrant the
white house said it had no advance
notice of the operation
not since the watergate scandal that
brought down president nixon nearly half
a century ago has america seen anything
like this the home of a former occupant
of the white house raided by fbi agents
donald trump was quick to link it to
upcoming midterm elections and
speculation that he'll run for president
again in 2024
he called it an assault that could only
happen in a third world country
on saturday he told a conference in
texas that the democrats feared his
recent polling
never forget everything this corrupt
establishment is doing to me
is all about preserving their power and
control over the american people
president trump is the subject of two
investigations one into the january
sixth insurrection on capitol hill the
other into claims he mishandled
classified documents a u.s official said
this search does involve government
records reported to have been removed
from the white house
prosecutors would have had to establish
probable cause of crime to obtain a
search warrant
donald trump says nothing like this has
ever happened to a president of the
united states
david blevins sky news in washington